I know some of you weren't born in 1982
okay but I started young alright so as
you can see they they for some weird
reason left out the very important term
quantum computing from the title of this
conference so I just got rid of all the
rest of them anyway
quantum computing it's one of these
really really interesting things lately
and about three-quarters of the things
you're gonna read about it in the media
are really wrong all right and so as we
go along here I'm gonna try to tell you
about the state of the state at least
from from our perspective but also kind
of tell you things never to say out loud
because ultimately it will come back and
Barriss you okay when you actually learn
more all right so so think of that part
as a public service of what we're trying
to do here all right now even though
this is a FinTech conference when you're
talking about the motivation for quantum
computing you really can't get away from
chemistry this goes back to a conference
in 1981 where the physicists richard
fineman pointed out really that if
you're going to model nature that is
exactly represent natural processes in a
computer that a classical computer and a
classical computer is really anything
developed with the architecture starting
in the mid 1940s
so the Eenie acts all the way up to your
smart phones right that there are gaps
in what you can actually compute there
right there's no a priori reason to say
just because we have developed this
particular type of computer that it's
going to solve every single problem that
comes along now people have I think
gotten the wrong impression through the
years and through the decades because
computers just kept getting faster we
had Moore's law at roughly every two
years they became twice as fast twice as
small they used half as much energy and
we became junkies right on on getting
this faster and we thought this would
always happened now depending on to whom
you speak Moore's law died ten years ago
or it's napping or whatever it's doing
but
that's almost kind of missing the point
in that in reality these types of
computers will not do for every type of
problem and there are some mathematical
proofs for this right
and so the work really began around 1981
and when when Fineman pointed out he
said well since nature and here we mean
basically atoms molecules and and
particles below that is based on quantum
mechanics something which goes back to
the 1900s really 1920 roediger
heisenberg and so forth if you build a
computer with a fundamental gate set
that responds the way quantum mechanics
responds and so here we are not talking
about bits and ands and ORS and nots and
then as we build those up into adders
and multipliers and subtractors and
eventually you get to Python right we're
not talking about that right at the
lowest possible level it's different the
best classical software engineer in the
world is not the best quantum programmer
in the world it's a completely different
thing
it's as if aliens came down and said hey
we developed this completely different
type of computer based on absolutely
different principles here it is good
luck figure it out okay and that's where
we are and that's what we're figuring
out what quantum computing will be good
for and we're very early so as just a
very quick example I this is the
caffeine molecule if you were to
represent so from a quantum chemistry
perspective the ground state energies
right so you think of atoms you have
neutrons you have protons but more
important you have electrons right and
these exist in this probabilistic cloud
around the molecules and if you were to
write down saying how much information
is expressed in a single molecule at a
single instant with respect to this
energy configuration it turns out that
the number of bits zeros and ones you'd
need to represent that it's 10 to the 48
yeah how does nature do that we don't
know
okay people have started religions over
trying to figure out how quantum
mechanics works right it's weird the
number of atoms and the earth are
estimated to be between 10 to the 49th
and 10 to the 50th so worst case the
number of bits you need is comparable to
10% of the size of the earth well that's
different right now if we think about
qubits and I'll talk a little bit more
about qubits here quantum bits when a
quantum computer with a hundred and
sixty of these qubits right is running
you could store that amount of
information
I'm completely skipping over how you get
all that information in there okay I'm
completely skipping over and then what
do you want to do okay but just to give
you an idea that classically completely
impossible to exactly represent we at
IBM have our largest quantum computers
50 cubits it's reasonable to think you
know progress the next few years will
get 260 and beyond
and so there's hope here all right so
first thing right as I said before what
things don't say never say quantum
computing will because we don't know
there is real science theoretical
physics theoretical mathematics that has
to be developed and you can't just toss
it off and say oh well smart people will
figure it out bla bla bla really it'll
be four years right no no right there
are going to be a lot of extremely
important scientific milestones from
here to wherever you want to be where
frankly we don't know how to do it
we have ideas about getting from here to
there let's say but we know that there
have to be major breakthroughs so when
people say something will definitely
happen in five years do not believe them
because probably they're not actually
building quantum computers and don't
know the actual issues a lot of times
people will say especially about crypto
the number of wrong things that people
say about quantum and crypto right
quantum will break cryptography next
Tuesday at 3 o'clock right I quantum
apocalypse is coming the largest
computer we have right now as I said is
50 cubits maybe others have slightly
more I don't know if there's work but
whatever the number of qubits we're
gonna need to break the types of
encryption such as an RSA is on the
order of 100 million we have 50 all
right sleep well this weekend if you're
in security ok all right now
breakthroughs may happen but it's not
Tuesday ok right all right
so therefore motivated by chemistry by
this example chemistry is an area where
there's likely to be some early
breakthroughs and we've seen some good
algorithmic matchups to certain problems
we had an Oracle a year ago September on
the cover of nature material design is
an area particularly types particular
types of materials oil and gas midterm
so we usually say near-term is in up
until the end of the 2020s and if we're
really optimistic we'll say 3 to 5 years
ok so just to give me an idea so so
chemistry you know mid-2020s drug
discovery much later much later you need
very large quantum computers if we can
build them if right we might if possibly
these are all important words here
artificial intelligence two possible
areas one we use quantum computing to
speed up the low-level math we do
particularly linear algebra somehow some
way right except quantum computers are
not big data machines you cannot push a
lot of information into a quantum
computer right so therefore you have to
reduce the size of the problem something
which you do classically right and so it
raises questions what does sketching
mean for input to a quantum calculation
so that's kind of scattering a result
the
other area which to me is frankly a
little bit more interesting is to say or
they're completely new algorithms so
take advantage of quantum computing such
as entanglement right fundamental
principles of the programming model that
somehow maps to something about the data
that allows you to do let's say
classification much more efficiently and
then financial services here you know
this is kind of a topic people are
figuring this out it's happening a
little slowly the big houses the hedge
funds have people who are working on
this traditionally they're physicists
who can code they know a lot of math
they're trying to understand how these
certain types of algorithms will match
we think it's going to be the first
areas of interest will be replacements
for Montecarlo sorts of simulations
that's for for risk analysis with
quantum computers and again we've only
done very small problems this is for
very small problems but it's at some
nice paper says that essentially you can
do your simulation because you can work
with much smaller sample sets on the
order of you know quadratic you know
square root of what you have and oh by
the way the samples you're taking or
higher quality right so that's that
that's the name of the game there so I
encourage you to to look at things like
this all right
quantum advantage is a period and this
is what I talked about before the 2020s
saying okay right over here in this area
we can show that quantum computing is
significantly faster than anything we
can do using classical methods classical
algorithms on a classical computer
anything we know how to do which isn't
to say somebody can't figure out
something and be really smart and come
up with faster classical methods right I
mean you know that I mean that's what
algorithm people do so there's a race
here right but in any case the point is
is that the future is a hybrid we are
not going to be replacing
the current classical computers with
quantum ones except maybe in like two
hundred years right they're glacially
slow for traditional computing things
and ridiculously fast for a special
class of problems right and so the mix
is how do you combine those two things
right how do you maybe rethink your
whole attack on on a certain problem so
when I say significant advantage I mean
like a thousand times better not twice
as good you want you want to run
something you know run it twice as long
right big deal right I mean everybody
has hardware clouds whatever you've got
here right so so that's that's what
we're looking for right this quantum
advantage and it will we're looking for
it in all those fields I mentioned and
several others as well and also if you
get down into some of the algorithms for
some of the areas I mentioned those
things can be can be used elsewhere as
well so that's just a subset of
industries and I think especially some
of the things that will be used early on
just for hedge funds and and portfolio
analysis and so forth is very broadly
used in many many different places okay
if you're not gonna let me use any math
I and no one else are gonna give you a
good explanation of what a qubit is okay
there are you know there's the spinning
doughnut family of explaining what what
a qubit is literally a doughnut the
spinning coin right all sorts of things
like this here's something else not to
say never say a qubit is 0 1 1 at the
same time people love this expression
and for those of you who know some math
it's because these people have never
heard of a linear combination right it's
like saying go three blocks north right
and four blocks east and being so
excited you're north and east at the
same time right so all we're basically
saying here right is instead of this
kind
zero dimensional situation where you
have two points zero and one really the
the computational space for a given
qubit is in fact two-dimensional and
here this is called a block sphere be
LOC H that two dimensions is wrapped
around the surface of a sphere and we
will arbitrarily label the North Pole as
zero and the South Pole is one they're
just labels they're not numbers right
and so when a qubit is operating the
value it can take on can be anywhere on
the surface of that sphere but the end
of the calculation when we poke it and
we measure it it must collapse to zero
or one where does it go well think of
the positions in some sense of you know
where it fits particularly vertically as
the probability of where it will go to
zero or one see quantum computing
because it's based on quantum mechanics
is probabilistic and so these numbers
over here right in this simple case
actually when you you take the absolute
value and square them actually represent
probabilities so what you've got and
know when you really start getting into
this right if you want to completely
ignore the physics you have to know
about five minutes worth of probability
you have to know a couple of hours worth
of complex numbers and then you probably
need to know a little bit more about
linear algebra and that's the basis for
the mathematical treatment of quantum
computing right from there on so if we
start here right we can say a qubit is a
linear combination of these two things
we'll just arbitrarily labels your own
one and what's even cooler is that a and
B are complex numbers they're not
integers they're not reading real
numbers are complex numbers and that
affects the mathematics tremendously and
gives you know basically birth to two
why all this works
so when we add one more qubit we double
the power so this is a traditional
computer it's a power nine core Moore's
law you
computer twice as fast twice as powerful
double the number of transistors roughly
speaking you add one more qubit it is
not trivial though in all times to just
add one more qubit right if I this this
is a 16-bit qubit device if I program
this one and you do this via microwave
pulses right if I'm sending a pulse down
to program this is the ringing of the
pulse actually affecting nearby qubits
so there are all sorts of problems of
how they're close together and the
intensity of the pulse and the size of
the pulse and things like this right so
quantum computing is in many ways even
beyond the simple semiconductor where
you get noise and crosstalk even more
complicated because these qubits really
are dying to entangle themselves with
each other in ways beyond classical
computers do so exponential growth this
conference I don't have to tell you what
that means right I will tell you though
Americans in general think exponential
means really really fast and that's the
sum total right one qubit we get these
two basis States a and B two qubits we
get four basis states think of it as
four pieces of information being the
coefficients and they're complex numbers
right so two qubits I can hold four
pieces of information and because it's
exponential with three qubits I hold
eight and now we're getting interesting
right now the growth is is certainly not
linear here and so with n qubits we have
two to the n coefficients to the end
these pieces of information and that
goes back to caffeine and why with 160
qubits we can represent that information
right that's how it works
mathematicians it's a tensor product
right all right
the largest computer we have is to the
fiftieth as I mentioned this is how many
pieces of information it could store
while it is running that's very
important not while at rest
and that's the computational space it
can work with right so it's problems
that would tend to explode right
exponentially inside a classical
computation this meant that this may be
suitable for not problems that have a
million pieces of data but things that
you can represent and once you start
computing with just blow up on you
that's where you look for to see if
quantum computing might be useful to you
if we get to 275 qubits the amount of
information is larger than the number of
atoms in the observable universe and we
hope in 10 years time this will be
considered a small computer how does it
work
we don't know okay that's your weekend
reading you know the philosophy of
quantum mechanics so it gets strange but
it's also fascinating from so many
different reasons these are the two
principles I talked about superposition
in several ways I talked about it on the
surface of the sphere what that means
and also as you get this exponential
blow-up here as well entanglement says
that two particles wherever they are are
so correlated when you know about one of
them you know about the other one
Einstein hated this he called it spooky
action at a distance he really tried to
prove it didn't work
he helped proved this is the way it
actually works he wasn't always right
now going to the title
please stop counting qubits all right if
you have four thousand really lousy
qubits it is not better than having 50
really good qubits for lots of reasons
it's a multi-dimensional measurement on
the quality of a set of qubits and how
many things you can do with them right
so here are some of the factors the
number of physical qubits the
connectivity what gates can you put in
this the errors the errors on the
individual qubits the errors on the
connections of the qubits decoherence
and things like this
so you know when someone says I have
more cubits than you ask how many of
them actually work right or how many are
usable then they usually shut up after
this okay so some numbers here Shores
this is our 10 million right number 4
here it's going to play out
this is going to be a multi-decade sort
of thing I think probably it will be the
most significant computing technology
for this century as a promo from a core
hardware perspective all right this is
what a quantum computer looks like I'm
finishing up here let me just tell you
that as we when we enclose this and cool
it down right down here at the bottom it
operates at 15 millikelvin it's close to
absolute zero the base of a quantum
computer is one of the coldest places in
the universe outer space is two point
seven degrees Kelvin this is much colder
than outer space right and it's being
able to do this and keep it consistent
that is part of why we can even begin to
build quantum computers all right we
just passed the 100,000 user mark in the
last 24 hours on the IBM Q experience
you can go and play with a 5 and a 16
qubit real quantum computers for free
the IBM Q experience you can join these
other people there have been a hundred
and thirty papers it's actually up since
I wrote that six point seven million
calculations have been done all by non
paying customers how uh Niger
quisque it is the open source sdk
yes that's sort of why I'm here at this
conference right
it's a extends Python three it has
several levels of programming below that
there is a quantum assembler language
and there is a microwave pulse open
pulse definition below that which is
opes also open source all right
Wizkid alpha aqua excuse me you said
libraries on top of that quiz kit Tara a
set of open source libraries at the very
lowest
level why spend millions of dollars and
build your own quantum computer when we
will let you program it at the lowest
possible level of the pulses okay so
with that there are lots of ways of
joining us
the IBM Q Network we bring in
universities people can partner with us
these are the advanced machines these
are always going to be the top quality
machines the 20 cubits and beyond so
with all of this to end this is what a
modern quantum computation Center looks
like that's in Yorktown Heights New York
about 30 miles north of here this is not
a lab experiment hundred thousand people
right and this is what we're aiming for
so if you come visit me in a few months
you'll see one of these up at the IBM
research lab in Yorktown thank you very
much
[Applause]